في تطورات هي السباق الانتخابي في تركيا
نفى مرشح تحالف الاجداد سنان اوغان
الانباء المتداوله عن نيات الانسحاب من
الانتخابات المزمنه عقدها الاحد المقبل
وكان مرشح حزب البلد محرم انجا قد اعلن
انسحابه من الترشح لرئاسه الجمهوريه وبرر
انسحابه نتيجه ما وصفها بالحمله الممنهجه
من التشويه الموجه ضده من قبل تنظيم وحزب
العمال الكردستاني المحظورين من الحكومه
التركيه
يوما وانا اتعرض لهجمات ممنهجه من الداخل
والخارج وادافع ضد سيل من الاتهامات
والافتراءات التي نظمها كل من حزب العمال
الكردستاني وتمم فتح الله اقول للمفترين
الذين اتهموني بالرشوه وبالرذيله عبر صور
الفيديو المختلقه انني اعلن عن تراجعي عن
الترشح لرئاسه الجمهوريه اتراجع عن الترشح
من اجل بلدي كي لا يلامح حزب على قبل
الانتخابات بانه كان سبب خساره الطرف
الثاني للانتخابات